it's part of the solution that we
differentiate between those who need
protection and those who don't and
people who come to Germany illegally
apply for asylum and basically know that
their application won't be successful
they have no future in Germany and they
have to leave our country we need the
agreement of our citizens to take in
refugees in need of protection that
means conversely that those who are not
in need of protection must leave our
country many come here claiming to be
persecuted but they're actually trying
to get jobs here they're hoping for a
better future in Germany seeking asylum
is not the right way to do that if you
think about the images we saw in bouts
and and cloudlets there seems to be
strong xenophobia in play is the
Interior Ministry taking any concrete
measures to guarantee the safety of
asylum seekers each state is responsible
for protecting refugee housing Germany
is a federal country and the states are
seeing to it that there are security
companies which protect these buildings
we don't want Salafists or
fundamentalists trying to radicalize
people in refugee housing and when there
are problems the police come we heard
about physical altercations in refugee
homes between refugees we want none of
that the security in these buildings is
guaranteed I know if tongue is given a
state